Denver Nuggets you may want to talk to
your ball boy about this I'm just
watching the game it's two minutes to go
ball goes out of bounds the ball boy
stops the game by walking over there and
wiping up sweat off the floor so the
referee has to pause if you all don't
know Joker runs to the referee he gets
the ball out fast if nobody's looking
he's going to throw a long pass for a
home run layup and now it's essentially
just like you're in transition playing
against a scrambling defense which is
how they had started taking control of
the game in transition Lakers transition
defense has been bad all year so now
they end up playing against the set
defense in making their run the guy
stops the game they come down they don't
score those are run Breakers and so I
hope they can identify that the guy who
actually broke their run up was their
ball boy going out to wipe the sweat up
off the floor hey my man when the game
goes down the court then you come out
and wipe that